The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: All right.
So today we're going to do
multi-stakeholder engagement.
This is a little bit
different than what
we've been talking
about, as opposed
to assessing the impacts
of the supply chain
and looking at where
environmental savings can
be made.
It's who can collaborate
to make those changes.
When a company is trying to
integrate different programs
within their supply
chain, often they
can't do it their
own because they're
working with supply
chain tiers deep--
further than tier one,
tier two, tier three.
So they need some different
eyes and different expertise
that can support their
additional effort.
Palm oil is a really
excellent case of this
because it's really deep in
a lot of different companies'
supply chains.
It's usually a very small
component of a product
that they might sell, like in
the case of Nestle's Kit Kat.
So who, before reading this case
knew about the palm oil issue?
What do you know about
it, that it was--
AUDIENCE: Not the best choice.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Not
the best choice, OK.
Did you know about the
environmental impact of it,
or more just that it
was a bad ingredient?
AUDIENCE: Bad ingredient--
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Ingredient, OK.
AUDIENCE: Nothing specific.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Anybody
else have-- yeah,
what did you know about it?
AUDIENCE: I knew somewhat
about the environmental impact,
but yeah, not--
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Just knowledge
that it was not very good.
AUDIENCE: Doing research
for the CDP project,
they talked about the RSPO.
That's one of the things
they-- my company highlighted
in their CSR, it's like,
we are 100% certified palm
oil or whatever, and I was like,
what is certified palm oil?
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Did
that cause you to look
into it a little bit more?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah.
So palm oil is a perfect
example of a material that
has a lot of
different stakeholders
that are being affected by
the growing of palm oil,
by who's sourcing it, and the
supply chain that's in between.
They have the growers,
they have the mill
that they process it
in, then they also
have a lot of middleman.
So that is where the
supply chain, because it's
a commodity, a lot of
times the supply chains
are very non-clear,
not transparent.
So they're not
able to see what's
happening deep in their supply
chains, the actual practices.
Did everyone watching
the Nestle video?
Because I feel like that was the
linchpin of this whole story,
where-- did everyone see it?
You guys all saw it?
Yeah, so that's
kind of where it all
began, where
Greenpeace decided--
they had been actually
looking at the palm oil
issue for quite a
while before they
actually when after Nestle.
And that was a
big turning point,
when they decided that they
needed to go after the brand.
And that's commonly what
we've found in our research,
is that going after the brand
is the more effective strategy
than actually going into
the deep tier supplier.
Because it gets
the publicity, it
gets consumers pushing
the hand of the brand,
and then the brand actually
looks into their supply chain.
So what I thought
we would do today,
I was originally going to break
you up into bigger groups,
but since we have-- well,
that's pretty good attendance,
but what I think I'll do is
match you up in groups of three
and you can talk about
the plan that you created.
Everyone had the assignment of
acting as a consultant for GAR,
for Golden Aggregate Resources.
And I want to see what the
differences were in your plans
and come to an understanding
of what you guys thought.
And then we can go
through the questions
together and see how
you guys went about it.
So why don't we--
you guys, three,
why don't we do
threes right here,
and then three right here,
you guys both triangular,
three right here, and then
you two, and then back there,
and then three in the back.
So we'll spend about 15 minutes,
and you guys just get your plan
and talk about the
differences you saw.
And then I'll be spot calling
on answering questions
and your group will have to
answer on how you look at it.
So were you guys' strategies
very similar or different?
AUDIENCE: Completely different.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Completely different.
In what way?
AUDIENCE: I said we go with the
complete Greenpeace approach
and point fingers
at anyone who's not,
and run our marketing
campaign that way.
And then Matt took the
completely different approach
that we should put Greenpeace
as an irrelevant outsider
and not let the outsiders
run the industry, etc.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So what
was-- why would you
look at it that way?
AUDIENCE: Just so that if,
particularly from the marketing
standpoint I wrote
about, from regulation,
so regulation is going
to be an unknown.
And you want to establish,
since the RSPO is the industry
and that represents the
self regulating body,
if you can establish
yourself as self regulating,
then you increase the
chances that you will not
require external help.
So hopefully the
Indonesian government
would play a hands
off role if they
thought you were
taking care of things,
and then you can be the
master of your own destiny.
And then from an
investor's side,
so that it doesn't look like
you're getting pushed around
and responding in a
reactionary way to everything
that any external organization
says so that there's
some confidence
for the investors
that you're not going
to change your business
strategy the next time someone
else comes around and says,
we think you should do this.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
So we have the
pro-Greenpeace, and then we
had the non-Greenpeace.
Any hybrid perspectives?
All right, we'll get another
team that haven't spoken.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think I might
have missed a couple of things
in that case study, but I really
took a market driven approach
to take some of these standards,
organizations they belong to
and set those as the low bar
and offer an even higher premium
product that meets the
Greenpeace requirements
and allow the market to
decide the best [INAUDIBLE].
And use that additional
revenue to drive change down
to the farmer and
government level.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: OK, so we've got
three different perspectives.
So why don't we diagram out
who everyone's involved,
and we can see what
everyone else was
thinking on who was involved.
Who are all the
stakeholders in this issue?
AUDIENCE: GAR.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: GAR, so we've
got, they're at the center,
the supplier of palm oil.
AUDIENCE: Rural communities?
AUDIENCE: Customers,
the direct customers.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Sure, there are--
so there's several customers.
AUDIENCE: I mean the
major corporations.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Major
corporations, the Nestles
and Unilevers and such.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
guess that would
be the [INAUDIBLE] brands.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So
they're out here.
They're a little bit separated.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: The farmers.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: We've
got the farmers.
So they're in between
GAR and the corporation.
AUDIENCE: Indonesian government.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Indonesian government.
Where would we put them?
They're kind of
out in left field.
Oh, we're going to test
my spelling skills.
AUDIENCE: Don't we
see the processing
mills are an intermediary?
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah, so there's
the mills and processing.
AUDIENCE: The certifying bodies.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Certifying bodies, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I would say
above the corporations
you have the consumers.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Oh, yeah.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Environmental
ag agencies.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
Where should we put them?
They're kind of--
AUDIENCE: There's the
environmental engineer type
people, and then
there's just people
who care about the environment.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: That's true.
AUDIENCE: And investors.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Investors, absolutely.
So they are kind of in between.
And we have green customers.
So you have anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Local communities.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Local
communities, absolutely.
So they're down here
with the farmers.
What about the people who
are impacted by the burning?
So it is actually the community.
Well, that would be also
local communities, but also
international communities.
I actually lived in Singapore
when they had the burnings,
and there was actually haze.
I was outside playing
soccer and coughed up
a lung because you
could actually--
the haze was so thick.
It's not a fake thing.
We've got international
communities
as well that were impacted
by slash-and-burn practices.
So you have all
these stakeholders
and GAR is trying to
figure out their strategy.
So you think about who
Greenpeace went to.
They went directly
to the corporation
and attacked their strategy
and what they were doing,
their actual material
that they were sourcing.
But then that got
translated back
to the actual company that
was dealing with the palm oil.
And then they had to
go through all these
different-- so did everyone
think about these as they were
going through their strategy?
Yes?
Sort of?
Not really?
No, you guys seem to
decide fairly quickly.
Anyone else?
Did anyone else not
account for one of these
and might think differently,
think about some
of these other
external stakeholders?
No?
All right.
So everyone thought
about everyone.
Everyone's good.
AUDIENCE: I forgot
about the mills.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: The mills?
Yeah.
The mills and press.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
about the other growers
and other competitors
who are joining the ISPO
and who might also [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXIS BATEMAN: The other--
I'm sorry, say it again.
AUDIENCE: Other growers
and competitors.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Oh, yes.
The other companies
that are-- so there
are also the other
palm oil companies.
So they're also
kind of in between.
No, they'd probably
be over here.
You get the picture.
Anyone want to talk
about their strategy that
are different from these
three, that they thought--
the marketing strategy?
Let's start with
the first question
in terms of how you're going
to market your palm oil.
Given the strategy they have
now, how would you go about it?
AUDIENCE: We thought--
we agreed that we'd
be more vocal about
publishing the fact
that we were trying
to take a leadership
role in sustainability.
So one of those
things might include
having an annual
sustainability report
or something along those lines.
And then we talked
about continuing
to work with Greenpeace to
maybe even set increasingly,
slightly, higher standards
or goals for ourselves.
And then again, just
talking about those goals
and putting those out
there so that it gave us
additional credibility
in the market
as a leader in that front.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So I don't
know if you guys caught
the difference between
Greenpeace and the Forest
Trust.
Did you guys catch
any subtle difference
of how each of those NGOs work?
AUDIENCE: The Forest
Trust kind of-- Greenpeace
was more on the
attack, it looked like.
And then the Forest Trust
was more of an interview.
You're like, OK, we'll work
with you to try to get what they
want, but-- they were
kind of the trusting--
AUDIENCE: They were like
the technical experts.
So they'd measure trees
and thinks like that.
They'd know the carbon
content of the peat soil.
Whereas Greenpeace was just
like, you're not doing right
and we're going to get you.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So they're
kind of the voice behind
to get the medial attention.
So maybe the Forest
Trust would maybe
be the more strategic
collaborator
if they were going
to have an NGO that
was pushing their standards.
Anyone else have
different-- so you thought
about a sustainability
report and then
working with an environmental
NGO to push goals.
To push, to keep them,
to push their goals.
AUDIENCE: As well as trying to
become a leader with the RSPO,
maybe backing away from
the NGOs and trying
to embark on the
global standard,
to bring it up to
the level you're at
and then use your influence
with the government
and with the organizations,
you can set the standard
to your advantage.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So
why did you think
that the RSPO might be the
way to go instead of doing it
more individually?
AUDIENCE: I thought
because people would
be able to recognize that.
People like standards, bodies,
they like things set better
than just an
agreement worked out,
where one party can
back out any time.
The RSPO, if it gets
big enough, it's
kind of hard for people to back
out and everything, and for it
to change.
So I think that the ordinary
consumer would see RSPO,
they've seen that
enough, they know
that when they're
just like, ours
is Greenpeace approved, well,
what does that exactly mean?
That might be different
for every company.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So,
some standardization
in the industry.
Did anyone think about the
Indonesian standard as the way
to go, in terms of who
they thought the local way?
No?
No one thought about that.
And why didn't you guys think
that that was the way to go?
AUDIENCE: Not a standard.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Not a standard.
But the two differences--
did you guys look at the fact
that one was voluntary and
then one was mandatory?
Did that play into your
decision factor at all?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we all
talked about-- i mean,
not like the marketing
fluff strategies,
but the bigger issue
bringing the product
to market being that only
10% of palm oil is certified,
and of that, a very small margin
is actually sold at a premium.
So the real issue is getting
out of the niche market
and making it more of
a tradeable commodity.
And to do that, GAR
already complies
by default with
the ISPO standards,
just because there are
global laws and regulations.
And then, obviously, the
RSPO is more voluntary.
So I think if they work with the
government more as law and not
as much marketing, it would
help the whole industry bring
more certified product to market
and raise their profitability.
And then the RSPO
could be like-- I
used the example of the LEED
building rating system, where
it's this voluntary
thing that you can add on
to increase the marketability.
So it would be like
a two tiered system.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So the
standard and the marketing.
Got it.
So you touch on the
fact that there's
a price premium
that may or may not
be making it to the farmers.
Do you guys see other issues
with making the sustainable
supply chain of palm oil,
what the challenges were
in translating what they RSPO
is doing into a sustainable palm
oil supply chain?
AUDIENCE: For example, as we
were discussing in the group,
[INAUDIBLE] and then
the RSPO accepts oil
from certified and
non-certified plantations.
So there are lots of blurry
points in the supply chain
that will make it
difficult to assess
if it's really sustainable,
and to what extent.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: All right,
so a major challenge
would be the transparency,
so you can't really
see where what sources
are coming in where.
So even if Unilever
decides that they
want to source 100%
RSPO certified palm oil,
doesn't necessarily
mean that that's
all they're going to get.
They're going to pay for it, but
that might not be the palm oil
that they actually receive.
Any the other
challenges you guys
see in this in terms of maybe
the RSPO as an intermediary
in the funding having to be
paid for-- farmers having
to pay for it?
Did you guys think
about that aspect?
AUDIENCE: Well, one of the
things that the ISPO addressed
was that the small and medium
sized farmers couldn't afford
the certification process.
So you have to address
that if you wanted
to take on certification.
AUDIENCE: It also
seemed like there
was a great amount
of uncertainty
as to the actual cost.
Some studies cited
Indian investors
buying stock in certified
companies because the fact
that they were certified reduced
projected risk and processing
disturbances.
They calculated that
the cost of certifying
would be mitigated
by or accounted
for by one day of a mill being
shut down due to global unrest.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So major
impacts to the smaller--
AUDIENCE: So there needs to be
some more industry collected
data if we can agree on it.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: More
information to make a decision.
AUDIENCE: This is
sort of [INAUDIBLE],
but if we take a look at the
sustainability on the supply
chain at the larger scale,
they were saying in the case
that investors and
financial people
were investing only in
plantations and in firms that
had a sustainable supply chain.
So I'm assuming that if they
don't have the transparency
to assess this, they
might just not fund
companies to produce palm oil.
At some point, there
might be issues
also in the supply chain
for its long term cost.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
So it's more of a
short term perspective.
So what else haven't
we covered in here?
So we were talking about the
burden on the small farmer
and their inability
to be certified,
and maybe the changes
in the uprun of costs
of certifying and changing
to sustainable practices.
What do you guys think,
what do the different teams
think about what GAR should
do about that, in terms
of treating the small
farmers as opposed
to their larger farmers?
No one thought about
the small guys?
AUDIENCE: I thought about them.
It's more you actually
struggle to figure out
how it can be incentivized
not to use all their land.
So thinking of somehow
a way to place a premium
on the product that is
harvested with less land
and putting in a cap on
how much virgin forest
they need to have in order to
be able to sell into the more
premium market.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Cap.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
things that we identified
during our discussion was
that the Indonesian farmers
or production was
not very efficient,
or they didn't have a
very high productivity.
So one way we identified to
increase production and please
local government and
local authorities,
but also the Indonesian
government in general
was to actually help the
small farmers increase
their productivity.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Oh, sure.
Be sort of an Intermediary
to get them to that place
so they could afford it.
AUDIENCE: I also found a
case that mentioned something
about bans and
third party audits.
So that's a very-- imposing
that relations on the farmer,
I think it should motivate
them to be more sustainable.
Instead of using that many
fees and scaring them away,
incentivize them
to use sustainable
practices and pay them or use
financial incentives to be--
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So
carrot and stick.
Did you guys think the
RSPO is more like a stick
because it's a costs burden?
Or how did you see the
RSPO certification?
AUDIENCE: More as
the carrot, I think.
Because it gives
them the incentive
whereas the ISPO
would be the stick.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure, yeah.
Everyone agree with that?
Yeah, I think sort of the--
kind of see the difference.
So what about
communication strategy?
We talked about
marketing, but then you
have all these stakeholders
that you're then
going to start deciding
what you're going to do.
So there's a-- we
thought about a report.
Sometimes I sit all
day in my office
and I read
sustainability reports,
and I think I'm the only
person who reads that.
So what other
strategies do you think
that GAR can do to
get down to each
of these stakeholders in terms
of translating what they're
doing?
AUDIENCE: We talked
about Justin Bieber,
but then we were actually
talking about famous soccer
players.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: I
wondered what you guys
were talking about over here.
Justin Bieber.
AUDIENCE: We just
used somebody that
is-- that all these guys can--
all these stakeholders can
relate to or see or know of.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
So maybe some sort of celebrity
advocating for sustainable
palm oil.
AUDIENCE: Or
sustainability, yeah.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sustainability
in general or sustainable palm
oil?
AUDIENCE: Palm oil.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Well, it's different.
AUDIENCE: I think in general,
it's going to be easier.
Otherwise, palm oil is such
a low-level ingredient that
soccer players [INAUDIBLE] it.
AUDIENCE: We were
mentioning in this group
that the education of the
farmers and the trainees, that
can also be a long term
return for the [INAUDIBLE]
of the population is
education in sustainable ways
to cultivate, and
also get in line
with the ENGO and the
certifying bodies,
medical communities, and
pretty much everybody.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
So one challenge that's here is
there's usually an upfront cost
for the company.
What would be your argument
for, if you guys can chime in,
what would be the
argument for that,
that this would be a valid--
AUDIENCE: I think
also a better return.
There is an upfront cost,
but if the farmers are
able to have better production
and better education,
then there might be also, first,
the better return in the end,
and then a better
relationship with them.
And they can also
be more cooperative.
And it can also ground for
the long term [INAUDIBLE]
in Indonesia and in
this part of the world.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think that's key,
because they were
talking about how
negotiating with the
local communities
was becoming more
and more part of what
they had to do before they could
establish their bigger farms.
If they had a reputation
of maybe providing
educational services
or equipment
training to local
communities, they
could potentially acquire more
land and do more business.
AUDIENCE: A lot of these
NGOs have deep pockets
and far reaches, so if
you can partner with them,
they would probably participate
in an education and training
program where wouldn't have
to shoulder all of the cost.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: NGO as a
source of collaboration.
Anybody else?
how about when you're trying
to get to your investors?
What do you think?
An avenue that--
AUDIENCE: Ford just puts
their sustainability strategy
into their business strategy,
so they have all the information
on their corporate
website, which is probably
where current investors and
potential future investors
are going to go to get
information about the company.
And then I also said that Ford
has a specific sustainability
department.
So if you had the
resources and the manpower,
that might be
something that they
would want to look
at doing, just
to help communicate the
fact that this is something
that they think about.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So I'm
putting in the [INAUDIBLE].
That's the Q&A source.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's also not totally
unprecedented for
governments to provide
some kind of financial
incentives or tax breaks
to companies that do good stuff.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Right.
So GAR could probably get a lot
of different resources going
to different stakeholders,
going iterative feedback.
They can see how
they can help them.
I like that.
All right.
Went to sleep.
So then let's think
about the bigger picture.
So we've got all
these stakeholders
to decide about a
marketing strategy, what
are the angles of getting a
more sustainable supply chain,
how we're going to
help the small farmers
versus large farmers,
and then how we're
going to communicate that.
So what are the overall impacts?
How is this going to
translate and impact
in terms of whether
you're certifying,
working with the local farmers?
If you guys have
some kind of broad
take takeaways from the case?
AUDIENCE: Well, I thought
one of the major differences
between what they're
doing now and what
the current certification
bodies are doing
is the deforestation issue.
They have to make a
decision whether they're
going to continue
that commitment
and, I think, maybe add
a certification level
on top of what's out there to
take credit for what they're
doing for the
deforestation, or to lower
their standards to
become more competitive
with the other companies.
And I think that
that's something
they're going to have
to make a decision on
as far as what they're going
to go with as a company.
And I don't know,
based on the data,
that there is a need for
something of that high level
unless you say you're going to
a market with the United States
or that's maybe more niche.
Because it shows that the sales
right now aren't in markets
that really care about
the sustainability.
They're more
cost-driven markets.
So I think overall,
they need to look
at where they want to
take their company,
if they wanted to the
niche sustainability
and maintain their
deforestation commitment
or if they want to
lower their standards
and become competitive
in the bigger markets.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah,
perfect way to put it.
What did anyone else think
about going higher or lower?
AUDIENCE: I'd say the same
in encouraging innovation
in industry, trying to find
other ways to grow the business
without the deforestation.
That was the
default for a while,
but maybe there are other
ways to use their land
and that sort of thing,
change the way they're growing
and that sort of thing.
I thought it might open up the
industry to some innovation
if they stay as
one of the leaders.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
Push the industry in support
of defaulting to the standard.
Yeah, absolutely.
hasn't spoken?
You have some thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, one thought I
have is that for [INAUDIBLE],
the company seems
like it's passively
responsible [INAUDIBLE] coming
from different directions.
So I think they should take
some more proactive actions
to take leadership.
Inviting multiple different
stakeholders [INAUDIBLE].
Especially for the
Greenpeace, I think
they should, instead
of just [INAUDIBLE]
respond to the [INAUDIBLE],
they should try and work
with Greenpeace,
set up common goals.
Because the NGO [INAUDIBLE]
environmental issues,
people tend to be more educated
in governmental targets.
So if they are convinced that a
company is making great effort,
I'm sure I think they
are going to promote
the brand of the company.
So this will actually help to
boost [INAUDIBLE] corporations.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Anyone else
have thoughts on implications
of working with Greenpeace
and getting them on board
with what they're doing?
What's happening
there with Greenpeace
as sort of the pushing
the buttons organization?
Kind of the same, everyone
saw the same thing.
What about overall impacts,
other overall impacts
of a new strategy?
So, pretty confident?
So we're going to--
we're still stuck
between adopting a
higher-- anyone think
staying with a lower
standard is the way to go,
that going with the
way the trend is
and committing to the
lowest common denominator?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] other
than the Greenpeace association.
I was very surprised
because Greenpeace
is defined as a pure
ENGO, as opposed
to ENGOs [INAUDIBLE],
for examples.
So pure ENGOs are known to
be extremely pure in the line
that they preach
and not to associate
themselves anyhow with
corporations because they're
not pure enough and they
have to [INAUDIBLE].
And [INAUDIBLE] firms
like all the primary ENGOs
are working hand in
hand with corporations.
So I was very surprised
that Greenpeace
would associate itself with
GAR and work with them, even
if the whole process is
not always sustainable.
For me, in a way,
they are tied with GAR
in a very consistent way with
what they do in a pure line.
But then, I don't think
they're pushing the buttons.
Because if we just take
a look at the bottom line
of their chart of what they want
to do, they've cut off now also
ties to GAR.
And they're also
associating themselves
with something that
is not perfect,
which is a huge break compared
to what they usually preach.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So you
felt like Greenpeace
should keep the hard
line and not associate--
AUDIENCE: No, no.
That's not what I'm saying.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Oh, you don't know,
it's just something you noticed.
AUDIENCE: I was just
surprised that there
was such a shift,
that they accepted
such a shift in their model.
Because usually they don't.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Right, yeah.
So a shift in
Greenpeace's strategy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
perspective of other firms
[INAUDIBLE] environmentalism.
And they're pushing the button
in what many people affirm it.
I think, actually,
the consequences
are [INAUDIBLE], given
the different models
that they had first.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Do you guys
have any thoughts on maybe,
because of this
and how everyone's
responding as the nature of
palm oil, or any thoughts
on the issue of the commodity,
kind of a commodity product--
material-- as opposed
to something that maybe
had a more clear supply chain?
AUDIENCE: Well, the problem
of the commodity material
is that it's basically
almost not differentiable.
And palm oil [INAUDIBLE]
commodity material.
So what is the added value
of this high differentiation
and high efforts and a
sustainable supply chain
if it's a commodity in the end?
So I think that customers of GAR
are really key in this process
by pushing the system toward
more sustainable practices.
But for me, they are the real
key of the whole process.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So you think
that the corporations are
the key in what
they're sourcing,
like the Nestles, or the actual
buyer, like the consumers?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
the ripple effect.
In the case, it
was Nestle, but I
think Nestle is acting like this
because they are engaged also
in sustainable practices because
the consumers are wanting it,
and they don't want to have
this ripple effect on them
like Unilever or
whatever, or they're
using suppliers are
destroying forests.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So who
thinks customers are actually
demanding this?
Sustainable palm oil?
Did anyone know about
sustainable palm oil
before they got here, when
they look at their products?
No.
So absolutely, great
point, customers
are a key factor in
this, but in the end,
when a customer picks
up their product,
the likelihood of them
actually knowing that palm oil
is in the product, so
sometimes it's a challenge.
AUDIENCE: I think a lot
of these companies also,
so the corporate customers
probably look at as much
of a risk mitigation strategy
as they do with anything else.
So my background before
this was in food and--
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Was in what?
AUDIENCE: I was in
food preparation.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Oh, that's great.
AUDIENCE: And I was
in a lot of companies
where they might not believe
that their consumers currently
care about what-- about the
sustainability of a given
ingredient or product,
all it takes-- they also
realize that all it takes
is like, you remember
the pink sludge thing
that basically shut down
an entire company in
a matter of a month.
It just takes something like
that coming out, like one
video, and the next
thing you know,
then everybody
cares very deeply,
and there's a big outcry, and
you might not have a business.
So I think there's
some element too
where they should be thinking
about a long term risk
mitigation strategy.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Sure, absolutely.
Future risk planning
and maybe learning
from what happens to Nestle.
Although Tony and I have been
working on a research book
on environmentally
sustainable supply chains
with a couple of people, Dr.
Blanco and Professor Yossi
Sheffi.
But we actually looked at
their shareholder price after,
and it did absolutely
nothing to Nestle.
It actually didn't
drop at all, so we
were really sad to see that.
But we looked.
AUDIENCE: There's also the
looming biofuel discussion,
which I don't know,
but I would imagine
there's even less transparency
in where you get that palm oil
and how it's used.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah,
I would encouraged
you guys to look into
ethanol, and you'll
see the same exact mess.
Very similar.
Anyone else who didn't
get to get to talk
have any overarching
comments on what
they thought about the case?
JB?
No, nothing at all?
AUDIENCE: I think
overall, addressing
all this stakeholders is a
step in the right direction.
Everything has a pro or con.
The impact on what
they're trying
to do to the environment--
it's in the right direction
and everything is going
towards a more sustainable.
There's still have a
lot of work to be done,
but getting involved with
farmers, stakeholders,
governments, even Greenpeace,
even though they kind of got
manipulated into doing this.
It actually ends up being
towards the greater good,
not only for the communities,
but for the environment.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So you're kind
of on the something's better
than nothing.
Does everyone feel similar, or
feel like the high standard's
the way to go?
I feel like we have
sort of a split in here.
Anyone?
All right, well--
AUDIENCE: I do have something.
Like I shared with
them, I just got back
from Hershey, Pennsylvania.
Went on the little
Hershey chocolate--
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Did you bring back
samples for the whole class?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
did, not for the class.
I ate what I brought in.
If you ever want to go,
it's a pretty cool tour.
You do wind up with
a lot of chocolate
when it's all said and done.
But what I was going to
say, what I told them about,
was one of the things they told
about Milton Hershey was back
when he was starting the
company after he went bankrupt
several times, once
he went down to Cuba,
he was trying to find
out about the sugar
that he was using, where
it was coming from,
how it was coming, basically
saw the deplorable conditions
that the Cuban sugar cane
farmers were working in,
and basically created his own
collective or his own co-op
down there, if you
want to call it that.
But did much along
the same lines.
He went down there, he
wasn't prodded into doing it,
he just did it.
He and his wife had gone down,
she had some medical issues,
and they were still
looking for some place
to make her-- she had
what we would say today
was multiple sclerosis.
They went down and they
created a school, a hospital,
put them all together.
Again, much along the same lines
of everything on the board,
by bringing them
all together, they
became more productive
sugar cane farmers.
They had medical care,
they had education,
they built schools and things
like that for them down there.
And it was basically this board,
but it was somebody just doing
it on their own.
Of course, he was making
millions of dollars,
that probably didn't hurt.
But along the same lines, just
without the NGOs thrown in,
just somebody taking
it upon themselves.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Well,
if every corporation
had a Milton Hershey,
then we'd probably
live in a better place.
Perfect story, I
mean I think there's
a lot of those examples.
AUDIENCE: Very, very applicable.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yes.
Yeah.
All right, great.
Well, I hope you
guys enjoyed the case
and learned a little
bit about palm oil.
So actually, one of the cases
we learned about in our research
about palm oil is that actually
two Girl Scouts found out
that palm oil was in
Girl Scout Cookies,
and they actually campaigned
against their own institution
and brought a huge issue against
the Girl Scout Corporation
of America, their own--
so it was actually
internal agitation, it wasn't
an external environmental NGO,
and that became a huge thing.
You guys should look it up,
it's a pretty funny story.
AUDIENCE: Did they change it?
ALEXIS BATEMAN: What's that?
ALEXIS BATEMAN: They did commit.
They did commit, so they're
in the same conundrum, where
they've done some, like a
certain percentage of RSPO
certification.
But the actual Girl Scouts who
started when they're like 10
and are like now about 17
or something, they're like,
no it's not enough, we want
you to have a higher standard.
So they're still
pushing the internal.
So it's a huge media thing.
But there's-- you can see
where different agitation comes
in within stakeholders.
So actually, what
we were talking
about with the NGOs and the
different types of NGOs,
you mentioned the
Environmental Defense Fund.
Actually, next week,
Environmental Defense Fund
is going to come, and they can
talk to your point a little bit
about-- I'm sure
you can push them
on some questions on
what kind of NGO they are
and the more corporate
partnerships style, way
of working that
they do, as opposed
to somewhere like Greenpeace
that just goes in usually
to attack.
So for the rest
of today I thought
I am going to just kind of
give you a brief overview.
Anyone else have any
questions on the case study?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned ethanol.
Are there any studies that
compare palm oil to ethanol?
I'm assuming there's
probably more corn used
in the world than palm oil.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah.
I don't know about the
relative quantities
and I'm not sure if
there's a study comparing
the issues behind that.
There's definitely different
issues in palm oil and ethanol,
but I'd encourage you to look up
what's happening in the ethanol
supply chain and
what's happening there,
but not off the top my head.
If I find one, though,
I'll send it to you.
So I thought the palm oil
was a perfect example.
It's like one of the most-- not
the most, but a very complex
example of multi-stakeholder
engagement.
This is just a small perspective
on how many actual stakeholders
are involved.
Within each of
those subheadings,
there's multiple
corporations, multiple mills,
thousands of farmers.
And so getting all
these people together
to agree on different
certifications
and how they're going
to actually run that
was incredibly complex, and
it's still very much ongoing.
There's still a lot of debate,
external debate from the World
Wildlife Federation
on the standards.
A lot of different NGOs are
commenting on how it's going.
So we actually covered--
some of the stories
that we've looked at and a lot
of the times when companies do
tend to commit to
multi-stakeholder engagements
or realize that they have
a gap in their strategy,
in their sustainability
strategy,
is when an NGO finds it.
And so that's sort ot--
these are just two.
So Nestle and Greenpeace is
what we talked about today,
where Greenpeace
activists actually
dropped into their shareholder
meeting dressed as gorillas
and totally blockaded the doors.
And there's other
examples of Greenpeace.
I don't know if they rock
climbed or parachuted
onto the top of HP and actually
spray painted toxic materials
on the top of HP because
they're attacking
HP for some of the
materials that they
were using in their supply chain
that were labeled as toxic.
So they have some very
Interesting campaign tactics,
but definitely get people
to look, especially
with the Nestle commercial.
This actually was
a different case
where the Rainforest
Alliance Network actually
attacked Mitsubishi.
So Mitsubishi is actually
three different companies.
There's a parent
company and then
there's Mitsubishi
Electric, and then
there's Mitsubishi Automotive
which is probably what we're
most familiar with, the cars.
But actually the parent company
was sourcing paper products
that were unsustainable,
and there's a lot
of clear cutting of rainforest.
And what happened was that they
just don't have a public face,
so the Rainforest
Alliance Network actually
decided to attack the
automotive company,
even though they actually had
no connection to the paper
sourcing.
So this is where NGOs are
using different strategies
to get it into the media.
So they actually had
sit-ins at the dealerships.
And what happened was the
dealerships then called
Mitsubishi Automotive
Electric and said,
we can't deal with this,
we're losing sales.
And then the
Mitsubishi executives
across three different
parent companies
had to actually decide
what they were going to do.
The sad story is that the
electric and the automotive
actually committed to
paper sourcing policies
and the parent
company still didn't,
because they couldn't get down
to the actual root problem.
So that's some of
the perspective
on how NGOs go about getting
into these complex problems
by pushing the hand of
the public brand owners.
So one of the most
clear, simple ways
that companies are
engaging is when
they realize that they
need help in increasing
their sustainability.
Chiquita actually
has-- I think they
started in 1992 with the
Rainforest Alliance Network.
They were getting
training and information
on how to grow their
bananas more sustainably,
so they're using the RAN to work
with their farmers and growers.
And so they've actually
used them for over 20 years.
Chiquita has sort
of a checkered past,
so they obviously decided
they needed to have a partner.
That was a one-on-one partner,
and they've actually worked
with them for many years
to look at organic issues
and Sustainable transportation
their products and all
of the above.
And actually, Chiquita
sought out Tony Craig
to do their carbon
footprint, so they obviously
need a lot of help.
They were actually
looking to Tony
to assess their entire carbon
footprint of a single banana.
So we'd talked
about that earlier.
Other one-on-one
partnerships-- Dell-- who
has a Dell computer in here?
Anybody?
So a pretty big brand.
They've actually-- one
of their major problems
that they were attacked
with was their e-waste.
So what are they doing with
the end of life products?
Several years ago, when
they were attacked,
I think it was
about 10 years ago,
they weren't doing anything.
And so instead,
now, today they've
partnered with Goodwill
as a collection point.
So the Goodwill can actually
collect Dell products,
and they also collect
any other products.
Actually, if you
guys look it up,
you can turn your
e-waste in there,
and actually Goodwill
collects those products
and then Dell pays for the
actual recycling and separation
of their computers so that
they don't go into landfills.
These are one-on-one
partnerships
where the company decided they
needed help with their strategy
and then they sought
out a partner that
was a technical expert in that.
In the case of Walmart and the
Environmental Defense Fund,
you guys will get a
little bit more insight
into what they're doing
in their partnership.
But when Walmart decided to
integrate a sustainability
program about in 2005, so
almost 10 years ago, they
needed many partners, and they
need one strategic partner
to kind of guide their
overall strategy.
So they brought in
Environmental Defense Fund
to look at their
overarching strategies
and how they were going to
drive that into their business.
So EDF is actually a
really unique story.
We're hoping to get the woman
that is actually co-located
with Walmart in Bentonville.
Their offices are in
Bentonville, Arkansas,
and obviously Walmart,
being one of the largest
retailers in the world,
has a significant impact.
So they actually co-located
their office there so
that they could have
a person on site
and work with different
Walmart individuals
as they come along with
different problems.
So that's sort of
a unique thing.
These are examples
of one-on-one,
where the company
decided they needed help,
they sought out
a single partner.
Other cases are
when a company has
a lot of different partners, and
this is true of many companies
where they've decided
they needed support
in different angles.
Starbucks, a major
coffee company, I'm sure
you guys don't know of them.
But they have brought in a
lot of different partners.
In terms of how they're moving
their cups and other products
to more recyclable-- and
using more recycled material
in their actual
products, they've
[INAUDIBLE] the Sustainable
Packaging Coalition.
They've had other-- for
more of their social issues,
looking at helping
their farmers that
grow their coffee
and their chocolate,
and they've partnered
with Root Capital.
In terms of how they're
actually integrating
recycling into
their sites, which
has been an ongoing
problem, they've
had working with the National
Recycling Correlation,
and so forth.
So each of these
different angles
that they've found
a blind spot, they
sought out a partner so that
they can improve their strategy
and also have an
expert in that area,
as opposed to
developing internally.
In some cases, some
companies choose
to develop that
expertise internally.
So they bring in a
sustainability person
that is an expert in
packaging, and that's
true of some companies.
And some decide
that they don't want
to develop that
internal expertise,
they'd rather seek
out someone who's
already a leader in that area.
Any questions?
And then the last
kind of major bucket.
Of course, these
can all be split
into many different hybrid.
Some people have a
one-on-one collaboration
and their industry
collaboration,
or they have multiple
partners and industry.
So everyone pretty much
just everything now,
most of the major companies.
So the other kind of
example would be an industry
collaboration, as we talked
about with the RSPO, where
they bring together
multiple stakeholders.
They are this
convening a group that
discusses the major
issues, and then they
may provide certification,
they may provide training,
they may provide information for
the company's stakeholders, all
of the above.
So that was-- RSPO
is one example.
Another example is the
Sustainability Consortium.
Has anyone heard of the
Sustainability Consortium?
OK, so that's the biggest
one, so it's all downhill
from there.
The Sustainability Consortium
actually came out of Walmart.
So Walmart realized
that they could only
influence so much in terms
of their environmental impact
within their own four walls.
They realized most other impact
was outside their four walls.
They're buying P&G detergents,
they're buying Unilever shampoo
and s and they realize all
their suppliers were actually
a major source of the impact.
So instead of just
trying to focus
on their own internal impacts,
they pumped a bunch of money
into making an
institution where all
of these different
suppliers, as well
as other people from
across the industry,
could come together
and understand
the impacts of products.
The actual outcome of it has
been kind of mixed and not
totally successful,
but it has been
a source of provision
for companies
to learn how where the greatest
impacts in major products are.
So they have different
product groups like shampoo,
and understanding where the
biggest hot spots of impact, so
that a company can address
that in their own supply chain.
So sort of serving as an
intermediary of information
for all these
different stakeholders.
Another one is the Electronic
Industry Citizenship Coalition,
EICC.
Pretty much every major
electronics group, Apple, Dell,
they're all part of EICC,
and that serves in a couple
different ways of helping
companies certify their supply
chains, and things
like conflict minerals,
understanding how to go
deep into their supply chain
to make sure they're not
sourcing conflict minerals,
or looking at alternatives.
Looking at social
issues on how actually
the end of supply chain,
how social issues are
working in manufacturing sites.
I'm sure everyone heard
about Apple's issues
with suicides and other
issues at Foxconn.
So that was a systemic
issue there that EICC
has served as sort
of a middle ground
on how to deal with
those kinds of issues,
going in your supply
chain and certifying
that your manufacturing
sites are of good condition.
The last one is the
Sustainable Apparel Coalition.
This is-- there's many of these.
You could go on forever.
There's quite a few.
But this one in particular
is looking at clothes
and how you certify the
impact, how you calculate
the impact of the clothes
that you're making,
from the materials you're
using down to getting down
to the consumers.
So they've come together to
understand a tool so that they
can know the impact there.
AUDIENCE: It seemed
like, say, ten years ago,
companies actually tried to say,
hey, here's what we're doing.
Then it seemed they all
stopped, because they were just
getting hammered.
If they said, hey,
we're doing this,
then they would get hammered on
five or 10 or 15 other things
that they just were like,
well, that's stupid.
I tried to say I'm
doing something right,
and you just bludgeoned
me mercilessly.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: You're talking
about the communication
strategy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
Walmart especially.
Walmart came out and said,
OK, we're wrong on all fronts.
And then they said, here's
what we're trying to do,
and then they actually
got hit again.
But it seems like
they've all gone away
from saying what they're doing
to just simply now touting
products, like we
said, this product
is using certified this or that.
So they focus now
simply on products
versus the corporate hey,
look what we've done.
It just seems like
they've all gotten away
from trying to put themselves on
a pedestal and just gone, well,
you can look at that product.
That's a good product, if you
really want to buy something--
ALEXIS BATEMAN: So sort of a--
AUDIENCE: They focus on that.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: A case
of a perfect case or--
AUDIENCE: I think that
the corporations found
that you can't say you're
doing something right,
because there's too many
people that will continue
to kick you in the shins.
I think they'll just stop.
We're trying, but
trying doesn't work.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Sure.
I mean, in our research
we found there's quite
a few different strategies.
So you have, if
you're a brown firm,
brown for meaning you're not
doing anything environmentally
sustainable, if you say what
you're doing and open up,
then you're going to get
kudos, because you're brown.
And then if there's
a neutral firm,
it's going to go either way.
So it's not clear if you're
doing some things but not
others, whether if you're more
transparent and communicating
what you do.
And then on the green side,
typically they can communicate,
they're just kind of assumed
to be a green company.
Has anyone seen with
their project companies
any issues with the
communication practices?
How they thought
they went about it,
they should have been
communicating it more
or communicating it less?
Any thoughts on that?
No?
Nobody communicated?
Well, it's a good point.
Especially in some of these
industries, they get a label.
A lot of these
collaborations and NGOs,
they get a label like
the Rainforest Alliance,
you saw in Chiquita Banana,
they had their RAN sticker.
And so sometimes companies
want to put that on there
because they want the consumer
to think it's a green product.
Some other companies
don't, because it
confuses the consumers.
So there's a lot of
different choices
and how this goes about,
and how do you choose.
So in terms of-- this
is just an example
of what the Sustainability
Consortium does for companies,
just showing you the
information source.
There's a lot of text
up here, so don't even
worry about reading it.
But what they have
done is decided
to do a literature review on
different products and existing
research and finding out where
the different hot spots are.
So they provide
this information,
this kind of hot spots
of where issues are.
So this is on chemical bleach
use in pulp manufacturing,
so in terms of paper, where
the major hot spots and impacts
are.
They've done a review of
the existing information.
They tell the companies
where the major impacts
are so the companies
can be aware that when
they're looking at
their supply chain
and then provide
them different KPIs
that they can actually
use to measure the impact.
So that's one example of how
an industry association might
provide information or
support for a company.
Does that makes sense?
Just an example.
So lastly, the
Environmental Defense Fund
will be here next
week, so actually it'll
give you a lot more insight
on how they actually
go about partnerships
with their companies,
which will be really great.
They actually put
out this report
with the Global Environmental
Management Initiative, GEMI.
There's a lot of confusion about
how NGOs partner with companies
and how payment works and
how the collaboration works,
which is an ongoing issue.
So they talked
about, first of all,
you've got to define your
overall objective that you
need help with.
So in the case of
Nestle, they decided
they didn't know anything about
their palm oil supply chain,
so they had to find a partner.
So the Forest Trust
was a good partner.
They were an expert in the
area and they brought them in.
So it's very, very clear
what they needed help with.
So then next would be
design the project.
So what are the criteria, what
are the overall objectives
in increasing the
transparency, and who's
a good partner for that?
So there's a lot of seeking
out the different experts
in that area, as well
as project execution.
So on the company
side, there has
to be someone who is the
direct contact for the NGO
that's going to provide
them information.
I don't know if you guys watched
a lot of the Forest Trust
videos or not, but Scott
Poynton, who's the founder,
he's very vocal, and I talked to
him in interviews several times
now, and he's very
vocal about the fact
that they're not
a pay-and-go NGO.
They don't want companies
just giving them
cash so they can say they're
working with the Forest Trust.
They're very much going to push
them on what they need to do
and they're not going to
let them get off easy.
So there's different
kinds of NGOs,
where some might be just
willing to take some cash
and be sort of a
figure project lead
and say they're working
with the company,
whereas other NGOs are
much more hard hitting.
Case of Greenpeace,
they don't really
want to work with anyone, they
just want to push companies.
Finally, one challenge will be
the measuring of communication.
A lot of companies sometimes
are reluctant partner,
because what are
the actual outcomes?
Vague, nebulous outcomes.
At the end, we talked
about some risk strategy,
which is a very apparent
and necessary thing,
but what are the actual
measurable outputs
for a company at that time
sometimes ends up here.
So these are major themes of
how stakeholder engagement can
happen.
And so- we will have-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we have so many
certification bodies and so
many different standards.
Some of them can be paid off.
You can buy some of
these certifications.
Is there any policing
body or any audit of these
certification bodies that
actually pull down those that
aren't really-- because
for a consumer, it's--
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Sure, absolutely.
I mean, it's a very--
there's Eco Label Index.
There's actually a group
that compiles all the labels
around the world.
I think the last time
I checked, there's
like 440 labels around the
world in 30 industries.
So it's a ridiculous amount
of labels, and most of them
don't mean anything.
There are within, most within
the United States and Europe,
there are marketing bodies
with the government that
can regulate if they feel
there's some greenwashing
or if there is the actual
label isn't actually
providing the certification
these standards it is.
But the fact of the
matter is that there
is very little regulation.
Some of these
marketing regulations
contradict themselves.
So unfortunately there's very
little in the form of that,
absolutely.
But I do see some of the
labels becoming defunct.
I actually found a label
that was called Green Label,
and then you just had to go
in and type in that you had,
you know, fluorescent
light bulbs,
and that people carpooled.
And then you could get a
label for your product,
and that's all you had to do.
So there's certainly a
huge range of the rigor.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
if there are things
we can learn from
the organic farming,
because they appear to be a
little more stable and more
regulated on that side.
So if there's anything that we
can learn from them and apply?
ALEXIS BATEMAN: Yeah,
organic is a perfect example.
They've been around
for quite a few years,
so there are also challenges
within the organic label.
The good thing about
organic is that's recognized
and people understand, for
the most part, what it means.
The challenge now in that is
that now the USDA is actually
accepting more materials
that can be certified organic
that a lot of different
bodies don't feel
should be able to be
classified organic.
Because they're trying
to certify organic baking
products, which has a lot
more inputs, as opposed
to an apple or a different
fruit or vegetable.
So we could definitely--
we should talk, actually,
at the-- later on, we're going
to have a sustainability supply
chain strategy
discussion and I'll
talk about organic
a little bit more,
and some of the
labels challenges
on what is happening in
some of these spaces.
I think that'd be
a great discussion.
Another label that's well
recognized is Energy Star.
Do you guys all
know Energy Star?
So there are few labels that are
being for the industry standard
and they're kind of
consolidating around that.
And so there are
some evidence where
there is to go to label that
is seen as rigor and the labels
that people don't recognize.
So in that way, companies are
consolidating what they use
and how they communicate
their strategies.
So we could talk about
that, definitely,
later on in this course.
I think that's it for today.
Maybe we should talk about
what else we have due.
What do we have due, Tony?
Do we have anything due?
You have no idea.
so let's just look
at it, because I
know that we've been--
So today was the
palm oil case study,
so we have-- what do we have?
Homework?
I think next week you
guys are sort of--
does anyone else know?
I think you're off the hook
for something next week.
It's-- oh, you have something?
OK.
Well, that's good.
I wanted to-- oh, OK.
Deliverable-- OK.
You're not off the hook.
I'm sorry.
Project deliverable number--
yes, one week from today,
and then we're going
to make that-- so we're
going to do a 10 AM.
Everyone OK with
this so we know?
Do we have a due
date already on that?
No.
AUDIENCE: It's already
on the schedule.
ALEXIS BATEMAN: It is?
OK.
All right.
So just plan for that,
that'll be your homework.
So next week, we're going to
have Environmental Defense
Fund, so make sure you guys
get here bright and early.
Well, not bright and
early, in the afternoon.
But--
AUDIENCE: For the
lecture on the 30th,
we have Noelle Selin, who's a
professor in the Engineering
Systems division.
There may be some reading
to go along with that,
just to prepare for it.
And we'll post those
in the announcements.
She's putting that together,
so we'll let you know.
ALEXIS BATEMAN:
Yeah, so just make
sure to check Stellar
in the next week.
So you'll have the deliverable
and some others readings.
All right.
Thanks, guys.
See you guys on Monday.